[Musik]
egal ich bin wieder voll in der sucht
angekommen täter friday night format
namen weil ich mache weiter ausloten
dienstag
so fehlt er eigentlich alles ausmachen
kann
er ist mein fords drauf geschissen
ja
da würde ich dir persönlich den über
video preis überreichen
dr
egal
ich habe meinen großen raum für land
gestoßen schreibt das pik die rufe ich
gegen den gleichzeitig wir machen mich
das boxen
[Musik]
also das war echt ein episches battle
das fabians auch immer übertreiben muss
er das habe ich seine mutter schon
letztens gesagt
weiß auch nicht was mit meiner for you
page los ist
sehen sie den job denken wenn sie zu
ihrer rechten gucken sehen sie eine sehr
seltene spezies eine sehr hässliche
sogar sie ist bekannt für ihre markanten
für schlitten- und ihrem doppelten
kommen sie spucken sie es ruhig an
ach das ist ja oder mal krass es einfach
sein spiegel fotografiert hat
besteht hier
hätte sich ja sein fazit ein kurzvideo
wie du es zur seite
die sache ist
ich brauche dafür nicht nur ein filter
[Musik]
st
ich hab wirklich relativ häufig
spazieren hier in hamburg und ich habe
vorgestern eine person gesehen die
einfach mit seinen beiden katzen an der
leine um die allzeit gelaufen ist
und sie geht mit ihrer verdammten kuh
spazieren
mit dem gehe ich
richtig
allein
ich mache das immer noch
[Musik]
dass dann der moment wo man realisiert
dass ein vogel besser als man selbst
[Musik]
der ist gefährlicher als kampfhund
[Applaus]
der löwe hat ihr einfach die nudel
zugeguckt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
schön schöner vogel den oder hasst ich
habe keine angst du dir
[Musik]
die größten komödien seien die einzige
scheiße wenn ich das wort gesprochen
[Musik]
na die katze hat sowohl auf ebay
großanzeigen bestellt
versteht ihr
aber die katze relativ
[Musik]
wer einen blick zur seite
der war so sieht hier ich könnte heulen
[Musik]
als wenn er diesen deine mutter
ist eine ehre
wo sie dich mein schatz was machst du
das macht nichts
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bitte sagen ja das würde ich auch sagen
das hat mich wirklich eins zu eins eine
situation die ich damals mit meiner
schwester hatte und zwar habe ich hier
als wir kinder waren sand in ihr getränk
getan hat sie halt manchmal geschrieben
und ich ganz schnell auf die schaukel
der sand
neben getränken
ist ja ekelhaft
ich war die ganze zeit auf die ganze
zeit weiter auf der schaukel ja
oma von der vorgeführten und allerdings
meine lieben freunde zu einer sache die
mir wirklich erst heute aufgefallen ist
und zwar haltet euch fest mainz da mein
sohn meine freundin ja vielleicht auch
nicht meine freundin madison bier hat
tik tok
wusste ich gar nicht schauen wir mal
rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
muss es los
gerade ich gerade auf die uhr geguckt
und das ist ich habe noch einen termin
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann na und
und wir sehen uns dann nächstes mal
wieder wenn er wenn es wieder heißt aber
bitte die 2
[Musik]
zum 1